in West Hollywood over the weekend a
supposedly family-friendly Pride Parade
involved a mostly naked dude being
whipped by another leather-clad dude and
the platform on which these weirdos
acted out their sadomasochistic
performance was not merely the back of a
pickup truck rolling down a Boulevard in
Hollywood no
the platform from which these guys are
doing it is the Democratic party
platform in 2024. in Arizona Democrats
partnered up with a drag queen at
another public Pride party to Rally
voters for the state's upcoming
elections
I have to ask I'm obligated to ask how
many of you are actually registered to
vote are you registered no shame if
you're not
no shame and you're not because it's not
too late to register for the next
election and turn the tide of all of the
hate the anti-gay nonsense in the State
House the anti-gay nonsense in the
Senate the anti-gay nonsense in Florida
in the United States it's insane it's
insane over 500 laws have been
introduced across the country today
today the anti-drag bill in Tennessee
was voted unconstitutional by an appeals
court so that's pretty incredible
gotta go vote back in California elected
Democrats honored the sisters of
Perpetual Indulgence a drag troupe that
exists exclusively to insult
Christianity for their supposed Courage
the Burly supposed sisters posed for a
photograph with Scott weiner a
California state Senator best known for
successfully lobbying the government to
reduce punishments for convicted
pederasts grown men who molest underage
boys but it is not just random state
senators across the country over in
Washington D.C longtime Democrat house
Speaker Nancy Pelosi will throw out the
first pitch at the Nationals Pride
themed night out
we are not even halfway through 2023 I
promise you you can expect to see a lot
more Pride participation from Democrats
as 2024 approaches and the reason for
that is that pride is their religion
pride is the official religion of the
Democrat Party replete with rights
rituals moral framework anthropology
theology liturgy and feast days pride is
the animating Spirit of their political
movement
it's their religion and it's gotten them
pretty far which raises an urgent
question for conservatives
what's our religion
is our religion the
anti-religion of liberalism the fake
neutrality the Preposterous separation
of church and state that the Liberals
duped us into believing or is our
religion the religion that built our
country that built our whole
civilization are we finally ready to say
that Christianity built our country made
it great and offers our only chance to
make our country great again or will we
continue to say and believe in nothing
while we all stand around waiting to get
run over by an ideological pickup truck
loaded up with a bunch of weirdos
whipping everyone with leather and
chains I'm Michael knowlesis the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show
just a moment a prominent Democrat
Congressman will call for a total end to
oil and gas which would cause us all to
freeze in the winter which would cause
many people to starve we'll get to that
first though
before we move on from our pride update
our daily Pride update now in this
liturgical season of pride
transheiser bush is down 27 billion
dollars
the question I ask off the top are the
people ready to fight back are the
people ready to articulate a serious
substantive moral call it what it is
religious vision of politics are the
people ready to fight back yes the
people caused transheiser Bush 27
billion dollars that is a shocking
shocking number of losses since April
1st
Bud Light sales have dropped uh ballet
sales revenues have dropped 25.7 percent
for the week ending May 20th
compared to the same week the previous
year according to bump Williams
Consulting so the numbers
that you're just staying down there in
the gutter transheiser Bush thought that
the numbers were going to dip and then
there'd be a week or two of controversy
and then they'd go right back up that
hasn't happened the numbers are down in
the doldrums they've lost 27 billion
dollars the people are ready to fight
are
the political leaders ready to fight
we like to think that our politicians
are leading the people and they provide
a vision and we all follow that's not
really what happens usually what happens
is the people lead the politicians or a
small group of the people when an
organized group of activists and people
with a Clear Vision they will convince
the politicians to go along with them so
are the politicians ready to fight back
not just on the pride issue but on all
of these important cultural issues well
one of our presidential candidates Ron
DeSantis certainly sounds that way
I've heard as a republican talk about
this Southern border for years and years
and years I will finally be the
president to bring this issue to a
conclusion we will shut the border down
we will build a border wall we will end
Mass migration into this country and we
will hold the Mexican drug cartels
accountable for the Carnage they have
Unleashed on the American people
love it absolutely great stuff but the
question of course is
where have I heard that before
that sounds kind of familiar to me it
doesn't sound very familiar that is I
haven't heard a lot of Republicans talk
about that in my lifetime but I have
heard one and the one I've heard talk
about it happens to be the guy that's
running against Ron DeSantis
DeSantis is very clearly staking out his
campaign as the Trump campaign but this
time we're really going to do it
that's it DeSantis is not drawing a lot
of distinctions between him and Trump
ideologically instinctually
tactically the only distinction that
DeSantis is drawing is he's saying I'll
actually get it done Trump couldn't get
it done I'm going to get it done
we have the same political vision
but Trump wasn't able to accomplish it
and I'm going to be more competent at
wielding government power there's an
interesting phrase DeSantis use there
the Santa says we're going to end Mass
migration into this country
that's the only place in which DeSantis
is giving himself a little bit more room
to the right
than
Trump has because Trump has previously
said we need to end illegal immigration
but we want more legal immigration than
ever but they got to do it legally and
I guess that would be an improvement
over the open border but the issue of
mass migration is not just about the
open border it's about Mass migration
it's about all the people coming in
since the 1960s we've seen the largest
movement of people ever in recorded
history
and that would be the movement of people
into the United States some of that has
been illegal but a lot of that has been
legal we take in two to now I guess
three and a half million illegal aliens
per year we take in a million legal
immigrants per year
million legal immigrants per year that's
going to radically change the face of
your country if that's allowed to
continue that's way higher than pretty
much any other country on Earth ever
so is DeSantis saying that he will
reduce legal immigration as well that's
an issue that people should push him on
because if desanta says he'll reduce
legal immigration and Trump says he
won't reduce legal immigration that's a
big Mark in favor of DeSantis
now it might just be that DeSantis is
using politician language and he wants
to give himself wiggle room in which
case okay then he's just running the
same campaign As Trump and just
promising that he'll do it better the
problem there though is even if you
believe that Ron DeSantis could do the
job better than Trump with the exact
same vision
sometimes you just want McDonald's
if you like McDonald's
and then one day Hardee's comes along
and says hey you like McDonald's well
we're going to do everything McDonald's
does better
we're going to give you bigger Burgers
they're going to be juicier Burgers it's
going to be higher quality beef we're
going to put it together in a in a I
don't know a more delicious package the
buns are going to be so come over here
to Hardee's because if you like
McDonald's this is just a step up
most people
are still just going to go to McDonald's
because even if the imitation of the
thing you like is technically better
you just like the thing you like you
feel comfortable with that thing you've
got a loyalty to that thing
Starbucks coffee is far from the best
coffee in the world I think Starbucks
coffee is pretty good I don't think it's
bad coffee but there are many better
coffees out there and yet if you like
Starbucks coffee and you see Starbucks
coffee next to some fancy Boutique shop
where all of the Baristas have like
fancy little twirly mustaches and they
do fancy designs in the Lattes or
whatever you're still going to pick
Starbucks because that's just what you
like and the other one might technically
be better in all these different ways
but you just you go with what feels
comfortable and what's what's nice I
fear for Rhonda santis that if he runs
just Trump 2.0
it's not going to work
because people don't want an imitation
of a thing when the original thing is
available even if the imitation is
better
in all the kind of
rationalistic ways that we can write
down on a piece of paper he's going to
have to differentiate himself this
immigration issue could be a place where
DeSantis can do it is where the
conservative movement is is moving is
away from this idea of
legal immigration good illegal
immigration bad it's clearly moving into
a place of hey we've just got way too
many people coming into the country no
knock on them it's just way too many and
the vast majority of Americans want to
drastically reduce all immigration into
the country so yeah we're going to
reduce legal immigration too that would
be a place to differentiate himself as
of now thou remains very unclear I don't
know if if you're working for the
DeSantis campaign right now and you're
looking at some of the poll numbers you
might not be sleeping all that easy you
might you might not you might think
there's a good chance but you might
still be up a little bit at night and
when you're up at night you gotta you
gotta just go out and get a helix
mattress right now go to helixsleep.com
with everything going on in the world
right now you could really use a good
night's sleep that is why you need to
check out Helix mattress he likes his
harness to years extensive mattress
expertise to bring their customers a
truly elevated sleep experience they
just launched their new Helix Elite
the Helix Elite collection includes six
different mattress models each tailored
for specific sleep positions and
firmness preferences I've had my Helix
for years now I absolutely adore the
mattress night after night I sleep like
a sweet sweet baby and I want the same
for you Helix says a sleep quiz that
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress
because why would you buy a mattress
made for someone else go to
helixsleep.comwles take their two-minute
sleep quiz to find the perfect mattress
for your body and sleep type their
flexible payment plans make it so their
great night's sleep is never far away
Helix is offering 20 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for my
listeners hurry on over to
helixsleep.com Knowles with Helix better
sleep starts now
speaking of presidential candidates
Senator Tim Scott has gone on to the
view he's gone into the lion's den the
Cougars Den the I don't know I don't
know what animals they are he's gone
into some sort of den
and he's defended his position as a
republican specifically as a black
Republican and he did it pretty
successfully
you have indicated that you don't
believe in systemic racism what is your
definition of systemic racism let me
answer the question that you've answered
or does it even exist in your mind let
me answer the question this way one of
the things I think about and one of the
reasons why I'm on the show is because
of the comments that were made frankly
on this show that the only way for a
young African-American kid to be
successful in this country is to be the
exception and not the role that is a
dangerous offensive disgusting message
to send to our young people today that
the only way to succeed is by being the
exception I will tell you that if my
life is the exception I can't imagine it
is but it's not actually here's here's
114 years yeah so so the fact of the
matter is we've had an African-American
president African-American vice
president we've had two
African-Americans to be secretaries of
the state the fact of the matter is that
progress in America is palpable it could
be measured in Generations I look back
at the fact that my grandfather born in
1921 in Sally South Carolina when he was
on a on a sidewalk a white person was
coming he had to step off and not make
eye contact that man believed then with
some doubt now in the goodness of
America
Tim Scott is really great in this
setting
Tim Scott is not great on campaign rally
stages you might remember his campaign
announcement was not quite at a Howard
Dean level of yeah but but it was
bordering on that and then the
microphone went out and he handled it as
well as he could but that's not where he
shines there are many candidates who do
a lot better on the campaign rally stage
Tim Scott does really really well here
I've only gotten to meet Senator Scott I
think a couple of times now he was on
the verdicts podcast with Ted Cruz when
I hosted that show and
one-on-one in an intimate setting he's
great he's really really persuasive
compelling seems like a really sincere
genuine guy and so when everything's a
little quieter and toned down here and
he can just make his case to the women
on The View
that's really compelling stuff
the problem for Tim Scott's presidential
campaign
is where the conversation went next
so what I'm suggesting is that the
yesterday's exception is today's Rule
and for us Jessica has met its promise
no of course the the concept of America
is that we are going to become a more
perfect union but in fact the challenges
that we face
50 years ago and 60 years ago should not
be the same challenges that we face
today and here's a way that you you
measured that when my mother was born
about 10 percent of African Americans
got a high school degree diploma today
is over 90 percent when you look at the
income when you look at the income when
you look at this when you look at that
everything's getting better so so Tim
Scott is
making his presidential campaign
a progressive presidential campaign
his
pitch is that America is always getting
better and so things might not be right
now but they're going to be better in
the future and so stop complaining and
don't
don't you know raise questions that are
too too harsh about America because look
at how much better things are today than
they used to be
and there are a lot of Republicans who
have made this sort of an argument
and in certain cases I guess it's true
in certain cases things are better today
than they used to be but in other cases
they're not that's true for everybody
that's true he's talking there
specifically about Black Americans in
certain ways the lives of black
Americans are better today than they
used to be in many ways though they're
worse
out of wedlock births are way worse
right now than they used to be for black
Americans marriage rates way lower than
they used to be for black Americans
crime rates murder rates way worse than
so things aren't just totally getting
better
the country is not in a place right now
where either side wants to hear oh
America is doing really really great
stop complaining just
grit your teeth and bear it put a smile
on your face and if we wish that the
country is in nice shape maybe it will
be
think about Trump's campaign Trump's
successful campaign in 2016 was the
countries in absolute turmoil we're all
living in the gutter the country is as
bad as it's ever been and we need to
make America great again
that's very different from the Rosy
kind of
right-wing liberal Progressive
conservative I know these it sounds like
these words are contradictory but
they're not really the
not radical Progressive view but the
kind of conservative Progressive view of
Tim Scott he says things are keep
getting better and don't worry they're
they're going to continue to get better
into the future
I don't know that that's going to work
I don't think that's where the country
is right now I certainly don't think
that's where the Republican party is
right now
and it only tells half the story
and I think if you're going to make a
pitch right now where we've got
really low
approval of of where the country is I
think you've got to tell that other half
of the story which is no a lot of things
have gotten worse and a lot of things
have gotten worse because of
progressivism if Tim Scott's going to
run a progressive presidential campaign
he's going to end up in the same
position
that desantises is likely going to end
up in with Donald Trump which is why
would you vote for the imitation when
you can get the original why would you
vote for the imitation Progressive when
you can get the tried and true OG
Progressive Democrat
why would you go to Peet's Coffee when
you can get Starbucks why would you go
to Carl's Jr today when you could get
McDonald's
why would you vote for a guy who says no
progress is happening and progress is
good when you can get when you get the
person who really totally believes that
with all of its implications
he's got to work that out he could be a
really compelling presidential candidate
especially if he can play to his
strengths like in those more intimate
settings which today with with the way
social media work you probably could do
that he's gotta I think he's got a fine
tune that message then we have another
candidate
which is Vice President Mike Pence has
formally filed papers
to run for president in 2024. he has not
announced it yet
an announcement now almost certainly
will come because according to the
federal government at least
Mike Pence
is a candidate for president
a lot of people are rolling their eyes a
lot of people saying Mike Pence has no
shot a lot of people are asking why is
he doing this he's not polling very high
the Trump people don't like him anymore
The Establishment people don't like him
because he worked for Trump the Trump
people don't like him because he
wouldn't wield his power to try to delay
the the certification of the 2020
election
he's a he's a man without a country he's
in no man's land right now
yeah
maybe he is you got to be in it to win
it no one knows what's going to happen
the libs could indict Trump who knows
what I mean Trump is an elderly
candidate I think he's robust he'll
probably live another 30 years but one
doesn't know at this age and so I think
Pence is is thinking right now look my
political career is not looking so
bright for the future because of what
happened at the end of the Trump
Administration so might as well throw my
hat in now what will the effect of a
candidacy be I think the effect of a
pence candidacy will be to help Trump
because there's one Trump and then there
are the other candidates and although
DeSantis is running in the Trump Lane
right now he's getting a lot of support
from people who really don't like Donald
Trump not from all of them not from all
of the never Trump movement or anything
but from a lot of the establishment who
wants a viable alternative to Donald
Trump they're backing Ron DeSantis right
now they're other candidates Tim Scott
Nikki Haley for fake ramaswamy
Chris Christie's going to run we'll get
to that in a second Mike Pence now and
so I I think the only people
the only person rather that that Pence
could be taking boats away from is Ron
DeSantis
the people who like Ron DeSantis but
they think he's still a little bit too
trumpy for them they're a little more
establishment maybe they're going to
give their vote to Pence maybe they're
going to give their vote to Haley maybe
they're going to give their vote to Tim
Scott
no Trump voter is going to say oh Pence
is in the race I'm going to vote for
Pence no Trump voter is going to say oh
Tim Scott's in the race I'm going to
vote for Tim Scott
so the more candidates get in the race
it's funny because there appears to be
some bad blood between Pence and Trump
right now but the effect of him getting
in the race I think it's just that he
helps Trump
now when you want to help yourself buy a
new car you got to check out carsync
head on over to carson.com Knowles
buying a new car can be a stressful
experience for anyone especially if
you're a first-time buyer or have no
credit before you walk into a dealership
and spend the entire day with the crowds
stress and potential to not even find
the right car you need to check out
carsing carsing is completely changing
the way you buy a car online by
partnering with Credit Agencies lenders
and over 25 000 dealers Nationwide
carsing provides you with everything you
need before stepping foot into a
dealership once you find the right car
at your ideal budget all you have to do
is bring your saved deal voucher with
you to the dealership to finalize your
next ride it is super simple even if
you're not in the market for a new car
check out car saying anyway carsing's
online window shopping experience goes
beyond mirror images you can dive deep
into each vehicle's specifications
features and performance capabilities
zoom in on craftsmanship of the Interior
Marvel at Cutting Edge technology and
admire the meticulous attention to
detail that sets these automobiles apart
from the rest car is saying helps make
your experience faster cheaper less
stressful go to carson.com Knowles find
the best deals near you carson.com
Knowles
you're so lucky we're all so lucky to be
here today in the presence of
the Precision 5 razor one handle plus
one cartridge kit
for just 14.99 from Jeremy's razors
Jeremy's lowest cost for a razor and
only for a limited time it's crafted
with a luxurious tungsten handle five
welded steel blades and a flip back
trimmer for a close smooth shave around
the hairlines hard to reach places but
remember
Precision 5 is no ordinary razor no sir
it's a sword in the battle for beliefs a
banner to wave into a new economy a
Precision instrument to force woke
companies to earn back your dollar and
stop denigrating your beliefs
but it is also still a razor and will
give you a great shape I shave for the
Jeremy's razor just this very morning
stop giving your money to what
corporations that hate your guts join
Over 125 000 men who have ditched their
woke razors and switched to Jeremy's
there's never been a better time or
Price go to jeremy'srazors.com
today
I mentioned I have to I know you're all
going to roll your eyes at me you're
gonna say Michael enough Christy posting
enough talking about the chrysosons
which some of us who think Christy has
something of a shot to have a role in
the race we're calling it the croissants
I know but I'm just telling you Christy
is apparently set to announce his run
and I'm not saying he's going to be the
nominee don't I'm not saying he should
be the nominee I'm just telling you guys
I give you hard truths okay I don't
Pander to you
I calls him like I sees him and here's
what I'm telling you
there is a non-zero chance that Chris
Christie
has a moment in this race
and the here's why
the reason why is all the reasons that
you're rolling your eyes it's all the
reasons that you're screaming and
wailing and rending your garments right
now no I don't want to talk about Chris
Christie that's why that's why he's got
a shot to go from he's not even showing
up in the predicted betting markets
right now
that's why he has a shot from going from
zero to I don't know 5 10 20. who knows
because
Chris Christie has
the worst qualities of all the
candidates
which oddly makes him kind of a good
candidate Chris Christie is a New Jersey
governor he's a Northeastern Governor
he's got fairly liberal positions or at
least over the course of his career he's
held fairly liberal positions for a
Republican
and so the establishment kind of likes
him
big business kind of likes him
the foreign policy establishment kind of
likes him he just I think just kind of
goes along to get along I think in 2012
Henry Kissinger called asked him to run
for president
okay
you got that but then he's also Brash
and obnoxious
and rude
he talks like a New Yorker he talked all
that all the stuff people say about
Trump they say oh Trump could be so
great if only he weren't so Brash and
obnoxious and mean and insulting you
know well all of that if only Trump
didn't do this Christy has that too
which is kind of funny and kind of
entertaining and generally speaking
the most entertaining candidates are the
ones that make it a little bit further
the most charismatic candidate in the
general election usually is the one who
wins
Chris Christie has both of those things
okay
all of the establishment squishy kind of
positions that you'd want to appease the
Chamber of Commerce but also the
obnoxious language that you'd want to to
infuriate Suburban mothers but but also
to entertain the base
he's not nothing folks there are some
candidates who are running who are never
going to register and Christy I don't
think is one of them but what does it
all really matter Trump is so far up in
the polls right now it is ridiculous
he's up nationally by a lot
he's up
even since the DeSantis announcement so
Rasmussen has Trump leading nearly two
to one nationally right now that's since
DeSantis announcement so the
announcement didn't didn't accomplish
what the DeSantis campaign was was
hoping which is that it would give him
the Big Boost and close up those poll
numbers now the DeSantis team is going
to say look just wait until we're on the
trail in Iowa and New Hampshire and
maybe that's true who knows he's a
talented politician he's got a very good
record as Governor so I'm not saying it
can't happen I'm just saying the
announcement did not do what it was
supposed to do the line before the
announcement was just wait until he
declares yeah the polls are bad now but
just wait until he declares you're going
to see those polls close up that hasn't
happened the numbers have gone in the
other direction this is true even in
Florida there's a there's a new survey
out of the 2024 GOP Presidential primary
shows a 20-point lead for Trump over
DeSantis that's from Sunshine State
Battleground polling conducted May 31st
to June 2nd Trump's got 53 support the
Santa says 33 that's into Santa's State
could it turn around is it early is
there a long way to go is Trump going to
get indicted like 20 more times yeah
probably
just telling you right now the state of
the race if you all you're doing is
focused on Twitter and the insular
conservative commentariat you probably
think
that this is a really really close race
you probably think that maybe even
DeSantis is leading but if you just look
at the rest of America right now if you
look at the broader numbers it is not
close could DeSantis close it up could
Trump collapse ABS so freaking lutely
we're a year and a half out
but right now people should not fool
themselves
the nomination is Donald Trump's unless
he loses it
now what about some other candidates you
know there's this candidate running
against Joe Biden not Marianne
Williamson not the dark psychic energy
I'm talking about
Robert Kennedy Jr
RFK Jr had been banned from Instagram
and Facebook has Facebook which owns
Instagram Has Lifted that band
why had he been banned well because RFK
Jr is skeptical of the medical
establishment and he thinks vaccines are
often harmful and he thought kovid was
essentially a big hoax and you
previously were not allowed to say that
on a lot of social media including
Instagram
now Instagram says okay he's back
he's back that's fine YouTube just came
out
and and YouTube announced that they are
no longer going to censor people for
saying that
the 2020 election was obviously Rife
with fraud
I'm still hedging my bets a little bit
so I don't I don't want to make a
declarative statement I'm just observing
that the new YouTube policy is that
the 2020 election was transparently
obviously Rife with fraud and we all
know it
maybe I stepped over the line there I
don't know but YouTube's saying we're
not going to take you down for saying
that anymore
okay great why
that's so strange
we're heading into an election year huh
there are two reasons I think why big
tack is starting to lighten up on some
of the censorship of conservatives the
first one is Twitter
that's the one the rest of big Tech
didn't count on which is that Elon Musk
was going to buy Twitter and that he was
actually going to be able to for now at
least withstand the forces of censoring
conservatives and he's going to make it
basically a free speech platform or at
the very least
reinstitute normal standards of speech
so don't suppress the conservatives I
don't think they were counting on that I
think they're afraid that Twitter has a
real opportunity to gain some market
share there and so Neda and Google and
alphabet you know Facebook and and
Google and YouTube are starting to
loosen up for that reason the other
reason though
that's that was the rosy reason the the
more
I don't know doer cynical pessimistic
reason I think is that those issues just
don't really matter anymore
oh yeah you can talk about vaccines you
can talk about the lockdowns and all the
fake covid science yeah because we
already did it we already did covid we
already locked it all down we already
made you inject yourselves with that
experimental drug we are yeah okay we
already got you fired from your job
got you kicked out of your school
okay and now now the evidence is out and
you're going to talk about the evidence
about how a lot of what we said wasn't
true yeah okay fine
yeah oops Whoopsie Daisy okay yeah you
got us right we're moving on to issues
that matter now
the 2020 election
yeah that's who cares that's over we did
it yeah we did it we we got we got
whatever strategies we wanted whatever
new voting rules we wanted even if they
were in contravention of state
constitutions like in Pennsylvania yeah
we did it and then the election happened
and then people thought about it but
then Biden's been president now for a
couple of years
yeah okay you can talk about how there
was a lot of fraud fun doesn't matter
because we're moving on to the next
thing
what's the next thing the next thing is
obviously
can I I don't even know if I can say
the word I don't on big Tech can I even
say the word you know that you know that
ideology
that says that if you're one
type of human being you might secretly
be a different type of human being
like you might if you're one
if you're like the kind of person who
has like a big Adam's apple and a beard
that you might secretly be the kind of
person
that has like rounder hips and
gives bro you know that idea I don't I
don't even want to say it because
they're clamping down on it so hard
you know which one I'm talking about
that's the new stuff
Pride
the sexual Revolution
the redefinition of family
the redefinition the reordering of
Education to support this new view of
family
all that's
the new thing and that's what they're
going to censor you for that's what they
already are censoring you for that's
going to be a bigger deal
conservatives often are fighting the
last battle okay well this is the new
battle and that's why the libs they're
loosening up on the last battle because
that one's already won
now they're moving on
to this one
speaking of conspiracies
and conspiracy theories this is a story
I have to get to
because of my colleague because of my
friend Mr Walsh
okay here we go for this from the
debrief which I had never heard of
before but this is the headline in the
debrief intelligence officials say U.S
has retrieved craft of non-human origin
here we go here's our monthly
ET story
here's our monthly leak from the
government from an anonymous source that
actually ignore what they're doing in
your schools and ignore the southern
border like the actual aliens entering
our country and ignore no there's a
spooky UFO look up there look at that
butterfly up there yeah
a Former Intelligence official turned
whistleblower has given Congress in the
intelligence Community Inspector General
extensive classified information about
deeply covert programs that he says
possess retrieved intact and partially
intact craft of non-human origin
okay he goes on and explains why
he's convinced this is E.T says analysis
is determined that the objects retrieved
are of exotic origin non-human
intelligence whether extraterrestrial
run An Origin based on the vehicle
morphologies and material science
Testing and the possession of unique
Atomic arrangements and radiological
signatures okay
nah
no that's not real
that's just not real one I don't really
believe Anonymous leaks coming out of
the government at convenient times just
generally but you put that aside for a
second
how do they know this is non-human
origin
how do we how do you know it wasn't just
the Chinese who made it furthermore how
do we know that this is not just a fake
out to hide our technology that maybe
has been
observed by hostile powers to pretend
that this kind of technology is not
really our technology
how do we know that this Anonymous top
intelligence official how do we know
that this spook this professional liar
is not just pulling a fast one which is
literally his and their jobs to do
don't really buy it
why else do I think the aliens are not
real because they are
if there is anything that kind of
resembles aliens in the world
and this is a hard pill to swallow and
they're demons
okay they're demons
aliens almost certainly do not exist
there's zero evidence whatsoever for
aliens existing but the universe is
really big yeah that doesn't
have any implication whatsoever for the
likelihood or unlikelihood of aliens
existing we don't know what the origin
of life is is a material cause
we do know the formal cause of of the
origin of life but that's a conversation
for another day
we we do we
well no it's a conversation for right
now actually inasmuch as we do know the
spiritual
aspect of the origin of life
okay we
Drive our life as a gift from God in
terms of the exact mechanics of how that
happened biologically and many many
years ago we don't know that exactly
which is why we don't know it we have no
reason to believe that it could or would
crop up anywhere else but furthermore
because we know that spiritual reality
metaphysical reality exists we know
there's a moral order we know that there
there are intelligible things in the
universe we're using signs to
communicate about things that are not
merely material right now that's what
we're doing because we know that there's
good and bad we know there's love and
joy and Hope and Dreams and all those
things we know that there is such a
thing as Spirit we know that we're not
just bags of chemicals
there's something immaterial about us as
well
demons and angels are just Spirit
they're pure spirit
in the way that an inanimate object
doesn't have a soul right it's inanimate
doesn't have anima soul
uh there are also things that are purely
spirit and we are both
we're rational souls and bodies in a
hylomorphic being
and aliens are the fevered
fantasies
of even people who are generally right
about a great many things
even people such as my poor friend Matt
Walsh who's Fallen under the sway
of the absolute inanity of the alien
phenomenon
you know
you know folks are you looking for a
better way
to organize your business finances let's
say you got to check out ramp right now
go to ramp.com Knowles are you looking
for a better way to simplify your
business finances across expenses vendor
payments and accounting if so ramp could
be a complete game changer for your
business ramp is a corporate card and
expense management software designed to
help you save time and money with ramp
you can issue cards to every employee
with limits and restrictions and
automate expense reporting so you can
stop wasting time at the end of every
month ramps accounting software
automatically collects receipts and
categorizes your expenses in real time
so you don't have to the time you'll
save each month on employee expenses
will allow you to close your books eight
times faster businesses that use Ram
save an average of 3.5 percent within
the first year ramp is easy to use get
started in less than 15 minutes whether
you have five employees or five thousand
right now get 250 dollars when you join
ramp just go to ramp.com Knowles that is
ramp.com
cards issued by Sutton Bank and Celtic
Bank members FDIC terms and conditions
apply
my favorite comment yesterday it's from
sway who says thank you Michael for
saying big fat blunts you have made my
day uh I'm pleased that I could make
your day
that was in response to the story out of
Canada which said that they are now
going to print warning labels on
individual cigarettes
and I just wondered I said okay you're
you're worried about the cigarettes
harming people's lungs and giving them
all sorts of diseases so you want the
warning label there okay well we know
that marijuana
and spliffs and Blunts and all sorts of
combinations of marijuana and other
goodies uh they can be more harmful to
people's lungs they can have more tar
than tobacco so are you going to print
the warning label on big fat blunts
Something tells me
you will not
on blunts
not on spliffs
not on doobies probably not even on big
silly bongs
well just after tobacco
that's where the Liberals are focusing
their higher
okay
I hope that you
are stocking up on some oil and gas
because it's going to be a real cold
winter if a congressman Jamal Bowman
gets his way Congressman Bowman a very
prominent Democrat
uh as he was whining and wheeling and
dealing about the debt ceiling deal uh
he called for an end to Oil and Gas
number one we need to stop drilling for
fossil fuels completely but number two
we need an expedited way to get us a
clean renewable energy or we will
continue to have these severe weather
events that we have been having for
quite some time and because of the
warming of the planet
Congressman Bowman I want to be as
charitable as I possibly can
is not the brightest bulb in the pack
let's say not the sharpest tool in the
shed Congressman Bowman once publicly
called me a Nazi and said that I I'm
gonna get his words a little off but
you'll get the point he said something
to the effect of I only want white
Christian men to exist
or something that I want to murder
everybody else or something like that
because he he
read a headline about my speech at CPAC
or saw a clip or read some of the speech
I don't know which made me wonder if
Congressman Bowman is literate
either I don't know I I don't know and I
don't want to venture any guesses but I
knew going into this clip okay this guy
is not the most conscious person not the
most
sophisticated Nuance to think are out
there and yet
he's a prominent congressman
and yet his idea that we need to just
stop drilling for oil
and gas
there are a lot of Democrats there are a
lot of elected Democrats
who would take up that cause if that
were put up for a vote today they would
vote for it
because they think it would make them
look good to their base and then people
would freeze in the winter
you might think well no one would
actually do that sort of thing no one
would ever actually kill off their
energy industry what are you talking
about that's what they did in Europe
that's what Germany did Germany killed
off their energy industry
and then became very reliant on Russian
gas and oil
and then when the war in Ukraine broke
out
the United States tried to use that as
an opportunity to pry Germany and Europe
away from Russian gas and oil and back
onto American Gas and Oil but Europe
could just produce their own energy
Europe could just produce nuclear power
they wouldn't have to really worry about
any of this stuff
but they don't do it they don't do it
because
bad rulers
unwise rulers with poor judgment
can gain power can wield power and can
make your country a lot worse that
happens if you were led by ignorant
people your Society will fail we focus
so much on ideology we focus so much on
well is this person a democrat or a
republican is this person a conservative
or a liberal does this person read these
intellectuals or these intellectuals
that we
sometimes forget that there is
a personal aspect here which is Judgment
does this person have good judgment is
this person wise is this person educated
has this person ever read a book has
this person ever lived life experienced
things that would give them any kind of
learning or not
Personnel is policy you actually the
people do matter here
the Liberals want us to believe that
people are all just interchangeable
automatons and you just kind of plug and
play like Legos but conservatives
sometimes believe that too
we don't think that the person
necessarily matters that much but the
person does matter personnel
is policy
if you are led by people who don't know
anything then your country is going to
make a lot of mistakes and pretty soon
it's going to be February and we're
going to be freezing because some dummy
decided to kill off our oil and gas
drilling now speaking of good leaders
I think they're going to indict Trump
again I think I think most people think
that they're going to indict Trump again
one MSNBC legal analyst thinks that it's
going to happen soon the last indictment
was let me see if I can remember this it
was because Trump
years and years ago
was accused of
groping no he was accused of raping a
woman in Bergdorf Goodman really
high-end department store in New York
and this was
an allegation that was made a long time
ago and it was about an event that
allegedly happened decades and decades
ago where the details kept changing and
then the woman said it wasn't rape but
now she's saying it is rape or I don't
know and it not statute of limitations
was obviously way run out on this but
then they extended it specifically so
they could go after Trump and okay they
go after Trump okay and now this is over
the classified documents where Trump
like every president in recent memory
took some documents after he left the
White House could be used to write a
book could be used for whatever purpose
and he was working with the National
Archives to get it back and working with
the FBI and then the Biden doj sends
their thugs to go essentially kick down
the door of Mar-A-Lago and make a big
deal about it okay so that's what they
say they're going to indict him on
here's what the MSNBC legal analyst has
to say
if you think about what we saw in the
Manhattan case we were looking to see
that defense lawyers were given an
opportunity to be heard that's really
the thing that you do in a case like
this at the final stage and we saw the
defense lawyers going in today to make
their final pitch about why there should
not be charges you know it is
conceivable that that could Prevail but
I think meaning that it is theoretically
a possibility but I just think in this
case staring Jack Smith and his team and
the people hearing the appeal that it's
extremely unlikely that they would be
hearing something that would lead them
to conclude that there should be no
charges so this is sort of the thing you
do at the very end
um I also think that there is internal
pressure even if they're not sort of
admitting it to themselves that this is
a case that needs to be brought
so that's Andrew Weissman he tweeted out
even pithier bottom line is he's getting
charged it'll be in DC and this week
and the question is will others charge
him will those be in DC or Florida or
wherever
isn't it strange
that these stories always cropped seem
to crop up
the legal threats against Trump always
seem to get hot whenever it looks like
he's going to win the nomination
this also helps the Trump campaign
because right now Trump's Rivals are
saying that the media want Trump to be
the nominee
what Trump can point to is every time
Trump seems to be absolutely crushing it
in the polls there's a new legal
maneuver to try to destroy his campaign
so you can say no they don't want me to
be the nominee but it doesn't matter
because every time they hit me it makes
me stronger I'm anti-fragile as Nasim
Nicholas Talib might say every every
time they punch me I I come back more
durable now is he durable enough to
withstand
indictments in New York D.C Florida
Georgia we're all over the place that
remains to be seen it might be seen this
week okay
the rest of the show continues now into
the membrane segmentum uh I find myself
very very lovable apparently not
everyone does and so there's a gal who
if I have this right
she I said something
this is in Inception Tuesday I said
something
and then this gal made a video wanting
to disagree with what I was saying
because she is a very left-wing sexually
eccentric kind of person apparently and
she wanted to
disagree with what I was saying but then
she kind of agreed with what I was
saying and then but now she's upset
about that so she's criticizing some
other thing I said I don't know I don't
know we're gonna we're gonna find out
together okay head on over to
dailywire.com
Knowles use code Knowles at checkout for
two months free on all annual plans
[Music]
oh